given some sample data how do we
populate a list view let's look at an
example of some contact data and how it
can be displayed in the list we start
with our raw data of contacts which is
three contacts as well as their profile
images then we pass this data into the
adapter so has a reference to it the
adapter also knows how to build a list
item layout for each of these data items
so could go ahead and create the layouts
for them but we don't need to create the
views yet until the ListView requests
that it needs them for example if you
had hundreds of contacts here you
wouldn't want hundreds of layouts
sitting around that aren't being used
then when you bind the adapter to the
ListView the ListView will ask how many
items are actually in the data set an
adapter will check the in the data set
there's three items so it will return
that to the ListView
now the ListView knows that it will have
to populate itself with three list items
now the ListView starts at position zero
and asked for the list item layout
located at that position it goes back to
the adapter and the adapter checks that
at position zero we have the contact Ana
the adapter knows how to create a list
item layout from the contact Ana so it
goes ahead and does that and then we
return it to the ListView and now we see
that the analyst item is located at the
0th position in the list next the
ListView wants to get the item at
position one so as for the layout from
the adapter the adapter checks that at
position one we have the contact Bob the
doctor knows how to create a list item
layout for Bob so goes ahead and does
that and then it returns it to the
ListView and now we see that the list
item for Bob has been successfully added
to the ListView at position one
now the ListView fetches its last item
because it knows that there was three
list items to expect it fetches the last
list item layout at position two by
asking the adapter the adapter checks
that at position two we have Charlie as
well as that image and we know how to
make a list item layout for Charlie so
we can go ahead and do that and then
return it to the list
and now we have the list item for
charlie at position two in the list and
we have our complete list